[Musique]
tous piégés le politique qui a annoncé
ce qu'il allait faire et qui s'apprête à
faire ce qu'il a annoncé et voit cette
perte de crédibilité faire obstacle à la
réforme des électeurs du second tour
macronistes contrôleur gré les syndicats
pris au piège d'une crise de confiance
malvenue dans une période de crise
économique marquée par le retour de
l'inflation et puis cette France
silencieuse qui pour partie le pavé pour
la première fois motiver mes résigner
pourquoi en étant arrivé là Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas eu des tas de grâces et
si la réforme a tant de mal à passer
c'est qu'elle a été empruntée au
programme de LR en concurrence pour les
voix afin d'élargir les soutiens cette
triangulation acerte faciliter la
victoire le candidat trop souvent ne
fait pas un programme et ne fait un
programme que pour gagner mais ici
Emmanuel Macron veut aussi et c'est
assez rationnel appliqué son programme
il va se piéger s'obligeant à tenir ses
engagements engagements issus d'un grand
écart problématique sauver le système
par réparti sur ce qui est un totem de
gauche mais aussi faire d'inévitable
compromis contre des soutiens de droite
et ceci pas encore d'entamer sa perte de
crédibilité
elle offre deux visages elle se dit en
grande majorité dans les sondages contre
le recul de l'âge de la retraite tout en
reconnaissant la nécessité d'une réforme
une réforme vue sous deux angles un
angle socio-tropique ou global ou
l'intérêt général est sous la contrainte
d'un équilibre des comptes et puis un
angle individuel ou égotropique où
chacun fait de son cas un cas
d'exclusion à la réforme on est comme
prise au piège d'une contradiction qui
ne dirait pas son nom oui à la réforme
si ce sont les autres qui en font les
frais s'ajoute aussi un horizon qui
atteste d'un conflit intergénérationnel
où les actifs d'hier retraitées
d'aujourd'hui sollicite un système par
répartition dû à la solidarité des
actifs inquiets d'aujourd'hui retraitée
demain
il semble pris en tenaille entre agir
fort mais pas trop fort agir fort pour
reconstituer un pouvoir de nuisance bien
utile
alors même que la réforme est l'arbre
qui cache une forêt de revendication qui
s'exprime en abyme défense du pouvoir
d'achat en tête agire fort pour aussi
corriger cette perte de confiance actée
dans les sondages ceci impose de
maintenir une certaine unité syndicale
mais aussi de donner des gages à sa base
mais il ne faut pas agir trop fort il
faut éviter le piège de nuisances qui
deviendrait contre-productive avec des
actions renouvelées assez inédites
préférant pour leur des manifestations
le samedi aux grèves paralysantes ces
opérations ont de moindre conséquences
en termes de perte de salaire mais
l'objectif est aussi de ne pas perdre le
soutien de l'opinion publique tout en
offrant une certaine résistance d'où les
menaces que l'on entend de bloquer le
pays aujourd'hui car dans un bras de fer
entre syndicat et gouvernement le
premier qui faiblit a perdu
le scénario le plus crédible est que la
réforme va passer votez grâce au piège
tendu au LR ils en rêvaient Emmanuel
Macron l'a fait ils ne peuvent pas la
refuser ils seront le pivot la variable
d'ajustement s'il leur demande son
honorées dans l'opposition mais votant
en force d'appoint de la majorité
relative mais d'autres pièges peuvent
encore se refermer un pourrissement du
conflit par un politique inflexible
pourrait ne faire aucun vainqueur pas
même le politique trop ou trop peu de
compromis pourrait nuire au compromis et
à la réforme tu es la réforme enfin on
observe aussi de la part des syndicats
qu'une action trop violente ou trop
longue pourrait être moins efficace et
devenir à terme contre-productive quant
aux Français dans leur ensemble il
semble embarquer dans un conflit entre
génération via une discrimination entre
les actifs d'un côté les retraités de
l'autre il ne reste qu'à espérer que ce
constat du tout ce piéger ne s'achève
pas dans une issue terrible du tout ce
perdants la des retraites nées d'une
triangulation équivoque pourrait
conduire le politique à ne pouvoir
sortir de l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment
entraînant avec lui de nombreux déçus
[Musique]